boa tarde eu estou aqui só porque eu sou
esquisita
eu vim aqui pra dizer que eu sou quase
um ali só falta a cor verde e aqui eu tô
falando daquela que sujeito esquisito
que não se enquadra em determinados
padrões estabelecidos por alguns grupos
né e fica sempre sendo estranho então
esquisitice começa com o meu nome é
vocês já devem ter ouvido falar com
consuelo é o nome bizarro porque raro né
é até hoje eu encontrei uma consuelo
viva além da baby consuelo que trocou
para baby do brasil imagino que ela não
aguentou a solidão coitado
então é eu queria entender assim nunca
tive a oportunidade de entender a minha
mãe escolheu esse nome e era uma
professora de inglês e o nome espanhol
pra mim não faz sentido nenhum
mas ela escolheu e ainda por cima o nome
quer dizer consolo aí eu fiquei pensando
poxa consumo pesado
aí cria uma teoria sim minha que ela
queria uma coisa e quando ela olhou
criança ela pensou é não é bem assim é
que eu esperava mas é o sol tá aí a
criança da saudável
tudo bem então fiquei nascer conselho
fiquei construiu esse esquisitice
termina por aí tava ótimo mas aí meus
pais se separaram estava morando sozinha
com minha mãe
e aí um belo dia quando eu tinha cinco
anos
ela morreu na minha frente
acontece na são as esquisitices que
estão fora da gente acontece pra nos dar
uma surpresa mas isso é normal
tem várias pessoas órgãos
nada demais até aí o grande lance é que
eu sou filha de um pai que é um astro do
rock gaúcho
escreveu o livro agora uma biografia
polêmica e assim como hoje na época né
dos meus cinco anos dificilmente poderia
ter condições de cuidar de uma criança
aliás nem de si mesmo eu acho que ele
tem condições plenas
então é as minhas visitas a ele eram
sempre cheias de surpresa né cada dia
uma mulher diferente que me olhava com
aquele sorrisinho meio e assim
amargurado
tenho uma filha e além disso fatos
inusitados como por exemplo um dia eu
queria um achocolatado aí ele diz assim
filha vai lá prepara de spam não tem
colher porque tinha uma pilha de um
metro de altura na na pia esperando para
ser lavada e todas as mulheres estavam
sujas
aí ele pegou uma suja lambeu diz toma
pega aqui tá pronta
então você imagina que exemplo de pai né
assim uma coisa ele com certeza a minha
família ficou muito preocupada com essa
influência paterna sobre a criança e
decidiu então me riffa e aí quem pegou a
bomba foi a minha vó eu meu avô também
pais do meu pai
o que aconteceu então foi que eu passei
a morar com eles ea minha avó muito
amorosa e preocupada ela tinha um
probleminha sem ela era uma pessoa que
não tinha senso estético não tinha uma
preocupação estética
a grande preocupação dela na realidade
era que eu tivesse bem né porque eu
tenho a mesma doença da minha mãe que
matou a asma e além disso tem renite
então ela me chocava de roupa sempre que
eu devia estar agasalhado do frio e não
importava muito que tipo de roupa que
cor de roupa era então era uma
combinação bizarra
nisso eu tomava corticóide por causa da
asma então eu também era enxada gordinha
e aí pra complementar a história toda eu
tive piolho e aí na praticidade da minha
volta disse vamos raspar a cabeça dela
beleza aí você imagina o quadro da
criança que jaime traumatizado né perdeu
a mãe na situação meio trágica asmática
façanha que eu sou até hoje
gordinha e cabelo raspado
aí o pessoal olhava pra mim dizia será
que a menina é menino é teu nome termina
com o néné deve ser menino
e aí eu ficava assim naquela situação de
exclusão é e aquilo me gerava
evidentemente quando criança muito mais
um sofrimento mas é eu resolvi mudar sem
vir à minha página da minha vida no
quarto ano disse assim ok se eu não sou
pop
eu tenho que me instrumentalizar de
alguma coisa que me de algum tipo de
amigo né que eu consiga conquistar um
grupo pra mim e aí eu decidi que esse
grupo ea ser a professora que me pareceu
na época muito lógico
afinal de contas eu tinha capacidade de
estudar de me dar bem na escola então eu
decidi que eu ia estudar mesmo para ser
a melhor da turma e de fato aconteceu e
conseguir conquistar várias professoras
ao longo da escola eu era sempre a
melhor aluna aquela professora que
estava ali na frente amava porque eu
antes dos alunos a pensarem responder
uma pergunta que ela fazia já estava lá
eu eu sei eu sei já completava o que ela
dizia então aquela aquele aluno que o
que a professora ama né
beleza fui amiga de muitas muitas
inclusive tem uma gratidão enorme que
viraram quase minhas mães eu freqüentava
a casa delas e ganhava carona ganhar
presentes tinha uma vida bacana e tudo
teria tido assim um final feliz
seria até hoje provavelmente uma cdf bem
bonitinha se não fosse o fato de que
quando eu tinha 9 anos
eu vou morreu também na minha frente
vocês vejam né pessoal não passei na
minha frente gente é um perigo
morreu ea minha avó coitada ela entrou
numa depressão tão profunda que ela só
conseguiu realmente se livrar quando ela
reencontrou um êx affair dela antigo e
aí foi aquele caso o livro de amor né
ele também estava viúvo e eles decidiram
se casar
é tudo lindo e romântico pra ela né não
fosse o caso de que ele era militar
reformado da assembléia de deus e ainda
por cima puxava uma asa para a
guriazinha nova inclusive pra mim então
eu peguei decidiu puxar meu carro e
disse não vou vou morar então com meu
pai tá na hora né tomar zinha consigo
lidar com meu pai
aí fui morar com meu pai foi fantástico
porque meu pai tinha casado com huma
fora dele então ele tinha 30 anos a
fotinha 15 eu tinha 10 era linda
escadinha
a gente andava na rua parecia três
irmãos fantástico
e aí eu resolvi também para me adaptar à
vida com ele entrar para o mundo do rock
eo eu estava bem na pré adolescência né
quem quem tem mais ou menos a minha
idade deve lembrar eu virei grunge então
andava de bermudão camiseta larga tudo
de preto cruze virada no pescoço cara de
mar
só que aí entrou a bizarrice mas eu não
quis abandonar os estudos
então eu era melhor aluna da escola
tinha até uma gangue na escola
mas andava assim e dava peitaço né de
olha só fechava fazia o roriz enfim é já
era por si só esse quadro já se cria sim
alguns no mínimo estranho nas suas
gêmeas
aí não fosse isso ainda não conhece uma
colega que fazer ginástica e eu entrei
para ginástica por causa dela me
apaixonei pelo esporte na hora
e aí foi interessante que agregou mais
uma esquisitice na minha vida porque eu
comecei a freqüentar eu sendo pobre um
clube de gente rica na época que fazer
ginástica e andava direto com as minhas
amigas então vocês vejam bem eu andava
com a galera do rock mas não bebia eu
andava com a galera dos estudos mas é
assim né de de camisetão permutam
rock'n'roll
aí eu andava no colégio com essa
situação então eu sempre era estranha
nos ambientes em que o circular não
importava onde pois então é isso foi
durante toda a minha vida escolar e eu
tinha uma esperança de quando fui para a
faculdade finalmente libertar se de
estudo e aí eu fui direto para a
arquitetura na fese a arquitetura minha
salvação entrei para arquitetura
logo nos primeiros semestres eu bem
empolgada né fiz uma maquete na cadeira
de maquetes que era padrão para todo
mundo ea gente tinha liberdade de fazer
o que quisesse em termos de locação aí
eu botei a maquete no meio do planeta
marte com direito a estacionamento para
a nave espacial em kaluga verde e o
professor olhou pra mim dizia é muito
criativa para ser arquiteta gente
frustados como assim eu era foi de minha
maioria achava o máximo aquela loucura
agem toda tudo bem aí mais adiante tirei
um cedo um outro professor eu fui
questionar ele disse que o trabalho
estava
muito bem escrito era cópia daí eu disse
como assim a copa então me prova de onde
o corpo de onde o corpo e ele disse não
é cópia você escreve bem demais pra ser
que o teto
aí eu decidir é acatar os conselhos
afinal de contas e fui pra letras já que
eu escrevia bem demais
achando que eu ia me salvar foi a
decepção da minha família
imagina saiu da arquitetura foi pra
letras coitada da guria é esse
estranhamento pra mim eu acho que ele
teve a maior digamos assim o ápice do
sofrimento para mim em termos de
exclusão foi quando eu atingir a
puberdade junto com isso veio a minha
vida afetiva né as pessoas inclusive
amigos não aceitavam muito bem as minhas
escolhas afetivas e isso foi pra mim
acho que o maior baque porque houve de
duas grandes melhores amigas
inclusive depois de uma das professoras
que ela quase minha mãe que o meu
comportamento afetivo não se enquadrava
naquilo que elas esperavam que eu fosse
e por conta disso elas tinham vergonha
de mim ea minha melhor amiga me disse
que eu escondesse quem eu era
neste lado para que a mãe dela nunca
soubesse e assim não pensasse que ela
pudesse ser igual
eu tive que ouvir isso né e foi muito
duro pra mim e por conta disso hoje eu
me questiono de porque que porque a
gente tem que esconder as nossas
bizarrices né porque a gente se esforça
tanto pra parecer normal sendo que todo
mundo tenha uma estranheza dentro de si
a gente pensa na sociedade de hoje todo
mundo sempre se esforçando para ter um
corpo que segue um modelo que é muito
difícil de atingir para ter uma vida que
supostamente vai trazer felicidade que
também é muito difícil de atingir e às
vezes a gente
hoje não consegue ter a felicidade então
tudo isso veio junto com a história do
meu pai que eu herdei além da miopia
falta de vergonha de assumir
eu acho que é isso que faz diferença né
na vida assim é meu pai não tem vergonha
mas não aquela vergonha na cara ele não
tem vergonha de assumir quem ele é mais
bizarro que às vezes pareça e eu dei um
pouco de descanso dele por isso hoje eu
posso dizer para vocês que eu não tenho
vergonha de quem eu sou
assumir uma profissão que gerava muita
vergonha que é o fato de ser artista e
também assumir uma profissão que não é
exatamente vergonhosa mas perante as
outras muitas vezes gera vergonha
infelizmente no nosso brasil quer ser
professora
sou professora mas continuo sendo
bizarra porque sou artista eu sou do
circo eu danço eu fiz o mestrado em
artes cênicas estudando performance e
gosto muito disso mas eu trabalho como
professora e o trabalho muito em
cursinho então vocês vejam que já fugiu
do padrão né
se vocês forem pensar o cursinho
trabalha praticamente só com professores
homens pensa em quantas professoras
mulheres vocês tiveram por cima e aí me
chamaram e a mim na minha chefe desse
assim o conselho vem gosta do seu
trabalho confio em ti mas faz o seguinte
tomou um banho de loja tá aí eu pensei
poxa é porque tu vê né e daí eu fiquei
pensando é padrão tudo bem a professora
que se espera
ou é uma velha chata ou é uma jovem
recatada bonita só não é do lar porque
ela trabalha mas de preferência uma
jovem recatado e aí fui lá eu me sentia
os meios drag cunha sim
montava para ir à aula tudo bem mas eu
gosto de down então eu ia com prazer e
um belo dia
no ano passado recebi um convite para
fazer um trabalho do g da companhia de
dança eu danço eu tenho maior amor
participar e eles me chamaram para fazer
um trabalho de literatura e dança uma
intervenção na biblioteca pública do
estado me deram um livro e eu peguei o o
livro caiu 16 o poeta e tinha um poema
converso que dizia que às vezes é
preciso a gente descer do salto alto
para estar à altura da vida e hoje aqui
um tão genial que eu fiz uma performance
ea performance era me vestir assim em
toda de plástico como eu tô agora só que
sem nada por baixo uns sapatos para
criticar essa coisa da mulher
plastificada que fica presa a uma ao
modelo que não faz sentido mas na
realidade é ela quer se libertar ela
quer sair dessas amarras que são
difíceis
muitas vezes complicadas de se libertar
mas ela quer porque ela precisa
justamente estar à altura da vida e aí
foi fantástico a galera adorou e aí sabe
o que aconteceu e postaram né
tirar um monte de fotos me marcaram no
facebook eo meu chefe no final do ano
disse assim com o seu não dá mais
vai ter que sair eu fui demitida por
causa das fotos no facebook
e aí eu fiquei questionando ele só sobre
porquê porque na realidade meus alunos
sabiam que eu tinha um trabalho
artístico já tinha inclusive visto e aí
ele disse tudo bem que seja artista mas
não pode postar isso no facebook
e aí o que eu coloco é justamente que na
realidade a gente continua repetindo
esse padrão diz com
e porque a gente tem que esconder o que
a gente é porque eu trabalho na legato
vocês devem estar vendo as fotos aí o já
viro é uma instituição que trabalha com
deficientes e aí a gente pensa a ela
escolheu seu esquisita e assume que é
esquisita mas e os deficientes que
nascem esquisitos e não tem como
esconder
enquanto a gente pensar sim a gente vai
estar condenando todas essas pessoas a
se sentirem menos ou se sentirem
coitados porque não se enquadra nos
padrões que se espera então meu recado
aqui é que a gente apaga uma história de
centenas de anos de mutilação de
assassinato de exclusão dessas pessoas
para que todo mundo olha para si não
sinta mais vergonha de ser cego de surdo
de ser deficiente é com algum tipo de
problema com o autismo de ser portador
de síndrome de down de ser gay de ser
lésbica de ser judeu de ser batuqueiro
eu quero que os meus alunos não tenham
vergonha de ser quem eles são
então meu recado é que vocês cada um
bote pra fora sua esquisitice porque se
todo mundo for esquisito isso que vai
ser normal
gratidão